Просто посеред ночі просинаєшся
і думаєш, що це шум дощу, а це пташки співають.
Кожна гілочка, кожен листочок —
і такий звук, як від пташок.
Ти думаєш: «Ну як це така
неймовірна краса на Одещині».
Я — коренний одесит.
Надя — корінна полтавчанка. Познайомились
ми тут в нашій хаті, в якій і живемо.
Я був вчителем у одеській приватній школі,
був класним керівником, викладачем біології.
Я весь час намагався витягнути дітей
з рутини загальноосвітньої школи,
тому я запропонував, щоб вони
не їздили трамвайчиком в зоопарк в Одесі
малювати тваринок, що у клітках,
а щоб поїхали в справжню експедицію,
щоб у них був справжній пленер.
Один із разів був унікальним.
Бо як прийнято в одеських школах?
Треба поїхати чи в Київ, чи у Львів,
а найкраще у Відень, чи кудись ще.
А я кажу: «Та ні, дітям треба їхати в село,
там наші звичаї, там обряди».
Перш за все — ми в Маяки,
на Дністровський Лиман, на Біле озеро,
на Турунчук,
потім — на Кінбурнську косу.
А потім, я захотів щось етнографічне, унікальне
і почув, що на Одещині є Кодимський район.
Поїхав подивитись, що це за регіон:
тут ще є гончарство і килимарство,
є живі майстри і тут унікальні фольклорні традиції.
Приїхав і закохався з першого погляду в цей регіон.
2005 року підшукав собі хату.
Добротну хату, я такої не мав навіть в Одесі,
бо я народився та виріс на Слобідці.
Наша приватна хата в гіршому стані, ніж ця хата.
Так потихеньку стали їздити з дітьми.
Я — біолог, закінчив Одеський національний
університет імені І. І. Мечникова,
а потім навчався в Москві:
вивчав релігієзнавство.
А ще пізніше настав такий вік:
скільки вже можна було ходити бабильом —
тай треба було одружитися.
Познайомився в музеї Гончара з дівчатами
котрі займались дослідницькою роботою
і запросив їх також приїхати сюди.
Найпівнічніший регіон Одещини.
Для того, щоб тут збирати фольклор.
В складі цієї експедиції приїхала Надя.
Я для себе зрозумів, що то моя половинка,
і Надя напевно зрозуміла, що це доля, як то кажуть.
Того ж року ми зіграли весілля тут у Шершенцях.
Зрозуміло що не сучасне весілля, а традиційне.
Намагались зробити його повністю
за обрядами цього регіону.
Можна сказати, що вдалося тому,
що його досі пам'ятають і в районі, і за межами.
Було достатньо багато публікацій.
Це був серйозний поштовх до того,
щоб в районі почали відбуватись ті процеси,
коли почали звертати увагу на те,
що тут унікальна культура.
Нашарування радянщини настільки замулило очі
і простим людям, і діячам культури,
що те справжнє, яке тут є, і ще було живе,
воно взагалі не цінувалося.
А цінувалося, щось більш сучасне,
як до прикладу якась естрада.
Після нашого весілля поступово почали
повертатися до того, щоб почати цінувати
і розуміти, що цим можна пишатись,
що це можна показувати.
Це має неймовірну цінність.
Найзнаковіша подія відбулась в минулому році — Кодема ФЕСТ.
Можна сказати, що цей фестиваль
створював весь регіон.
Ми змогли об'єднатись всі,
разом об'єднати район
і це був такий серйозний, соціальний проєкт —
він зачепив усіх в районі.
Ті совдепії ввели їм комплекс, дуже гнітючий,
що це все не варте уваги.
Коли ми вдягаємо строї, ті бабусі —
носії цієї культури —
вони сміються: «А з вас ніхто сміятись не буде,
що ви це дрантя вдягнули?»
«А я дівувала в такому одязі».
«А я віддавалась [виходила заміж]
в оцьому шарафані», —
і дарує мені цей шарафан.
Це ж треба так перевернути свідомість людей,
щоб те рідне, в якому вони виросли,
яке вони виткали своїми руками,
що вони його соромляться.
Це глибоко. Оце старше покоління,
яке є носіями.
А уявіть, що з тими поколіннями,
які вже цю традицію не перейняли
через цей же комплекс,
який їм нав'язували роками.
Коли почали досліджувати весільний обряд,
ми зрозуміли, що в кожному селі
є дивовижно свій, унікальний весільний обряд.
Наше село Шершенці відрізняється від сусіднього.
Є схожість, але й є і відмінності
Це ж багатюща культура, бо такого поняття
як національний костюм немає.
Є тільки костюм конкретного села.
А якщо ще глибше копнути,
то і в кожній родині було щось своє.
Це ж взагалі феноменально.
У людей менталітет закритості.
По-перше, люди все життя, з роду в рід, жили в селі.
Приїжджає «якась нова вискочка» —
людина, яка робить все по новому.
Вони знають, що баба навчила маму,
мама навчила дочку
чи дід навчив тата, тато сина навчив —
і це правильно.
Не може бути іншої правильно думки.
А тут приїхала нова людина,
і вона робить все по новому.
Що з цього вийде — ну це просто смішно.
В консервативному суспільстві
все нове викликає протест,
тому мешканець міста, який приїжджає
і хоче жити краще й по-іншому,
то наша заздрість, така, яка є у нас,
на жаль, грає негативну роль.
2010 року ми вирішили переїхати з міста у село Шершенці
і заснувати тут маленьку еко-ферму.
І от основним напрямом нашої роботи стала...
Крім того, що ми зробили гостьову хату
і приймаємо до себе туристів,
ми переробляємо молоко
і робимо молочну продукцію.
За чотири роки наше виробництво збільшилось.
Ми маємо справжній молочний цех.
Виробляємо більше двадцяти видів
молочної продукції,
зокрема різну кисло-молочну продукцію.
Наприклад, звичайний кефір
чи як от пряжене молоко,
традиційний біфідойогурт, чи йогурт з фруктами.
Ми не планували робити нашу першу продукцію,
але у нас народився син і ми хотіли,
щоб він їв справжню, натуральну їжу.
Для себе, для нашого сина почали
робити ряжанку, сметану, йогурти,
а потім, ми вирішили, що це, таке смачне
і у нас його вже була певна кількість...
Ми вирішили, що це можна реалізовувати,
можна ділитись з людьми і з цього заробляти.
Завдяки чому, ми можемо розвиватися.
Ми почали пропонувати це в еко-магазини Одеси
і  вже чотири роки ми продаємо нашу продукцію.
На жаль, радянський період зробив
в головах людей таке, що вони кажуть:
«В колгоспі ще можна було працювати,
бо там можна вкрасти».
«Там немає ніякої, такої відповідальності не було,
а на господаря, це йти найметувати».
Комплекс меншовартості, що ти йдеш
найметувати — і людям це так нав'язали,
що йти і заробити грошей —
це якийсь дискомфорт для них.
Люди поступово до цього звикають,
сім років тому з людьми було дуже складно [працювати].
Я як мешканець міста знайшов великий скарб.
Скарб — наша земля.
Ми приїхали на цю землю, ця земля багата.
Хотілося би, щоб більшість людей з великих міст,
які ютяться, десь в маленьких квартирах,
десь ходять на заробітки,
просто стали господарями
на своїй землі, яка пустує.
Наша місія — говорити всім людям,
що ми повинні бути господарями на своїй землі.
Переїжджати з великих міст,
брати пусті землі, володіти ними,
ставати господарями, вирощувати городи,
сади, виноградники.
Це все годує, воно приносить прибуток
і тут можна прожити будь-якій родині.
Але як кажуть місцеві, треба мати
трошки клепку в голові.
Це все можна зробити так,
щоб воно забезпечувало тебе
і давало роботу іншим.